great mmm Mario yeah we are back welcome
to the giant podcast welcome guys
welcome welcome
[ __ ] welcome such a such a nice thing
good said welcome go ok well now well
come all right let's talk curses brought
to you by the gen in Julian podcast by
Squarespace
check out Squarespace calm for your
website needs they have some of the
cleanest best-looking most
professional-looking easy to use
templates service to make your own
website go to squarespace.com and enter
products code JJ at checkout for 10% off
your website to make yourself a cool
website and Thank You Squarespace for
supporting us and thank you for these
awesome t-shirts if it's great no I was
like you should wear this medium cuz it
like makes your muscles look really big
alright that makes your shirt look like
it can't like even handle your body yeah
oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a look it's a look anyway thanks
for the shirt thing thank you for
sponsoring a podcast so this week we
have a podcast that you guys will enjoy
yeah it's one of the most requested
podcasts that we get which is shocking
to me because it was one of my favorite
ones to do because it's all I do in my
free time anyways yeah and conspiracy
theories is what we're talking about
seriously theories um because you guys
know that I go so far down the rabbit
hole on the internet all the time and I
love it
we did do a celebrity conspiracy theory
yeah so we did one conspiracy theories
podcast which was pretty serious we both
gathered some really interesting
conspiracy there's and did that podcast
and we did a part two but it was more of
like humorous conspiracy theories funny
celebrity stuff like that so this I
would consider part two but it's
technically part three yeah I guess so
this is the second serial part 1 billion
for my brain yeah Jenna mean Genesis
around long before we even did the
podcast and looks up conspiracy theories
all over the place and she definitely
for this podcast harder than any other
podcast so oh well now you're gonna put
way too much pressure on me I was just
falling down black holes that's all like
I just I take a long time because you
get distracted by 50 other conspiracy
theories that you got to know about so
then you can you know what you all see
exactly you want to make sure you have
the best ones yeah but I'm also just you
know procrastinating cuz I want to read
about things selfish so me I'm selfish
guys in this podcast is late it's
because each other's my selfish desire
for knowledge of what other people are
thinking yeah um anyway would you like
to start your first conspiracy do you
want me to I would like you to because
God very curious to see how badly you
beat me okay cool so the first one is
like what we've been talking about for
the past few days or whatever and the
Internet's been crazy for a little while
I don't know exactly because I didn't I
wasn't looking at dates cuz I'm you know
busy reading in getting my mind blown
I'm not a hundred percent sure when this
actually came out but the Berenstein
bears conspiracy theory hmm um like my
mind exploded I just I can't explode
dead why I read it because um most of us
well I think it started off as one
person one person really liked the
Berenstein bears I believe it's this a
conspiracy blog that I've been on
although I can't I don't know who to
credit stranger dimensions is the name
of the blog or website I don't know
maybe uses Squarespace uh-huh um but
anyways it's really well done because
it's just I think just a person or maybe
two I don't know but whatever I believed
that he had gone back and looked at his
Berenstein bears books because he really
enjoyed Berenstein bears and distinctly
remembers them being spelled with an e
at the end like Berenstein st ein
instead of sta I N so he went back and
looked at his books realized that they
said Barents like berenstain bears okay
and so he instantly like googled it
starts looking all over the place and
like
on Wikipedia on everything on like the
entire Internet it just says Berenstain
Bears everywhere so it's sort of like
took off on the internet or being like I
completely remember it being the
Berenstein bears that's why everybody
says Berenstein bears nom berenstain
bears and it's just completely it's not
a thing it doesn't exist it's been
berenstain bears it always has been so
the theory there's a couple of theories
as to why this is like that's peculiar
what was it before you were born it's
usually important oh I've heard of the
book so I don't think I ever read him as
a kid but right I know that sounds weird
right like everyone just collectively
all being like what the [ __ ]
so there's a couple of theories what are
they one of the theories is well we
can't nobody knows for sure it's just
[ __ ] weird one of the theories is
that we were in like a a dimension in
theory and then sometime between you
know 1997 and 2001 or some [ __ ] we
switched into an A dimension like we
basically traveled into a collectively a
parallel universe something changed
whatever path we were on and the only
thing that still exists of them being
the Berenstein bears is the fact that we
all distinctly remember that being
spelled with an E
okay isn't that crazy yeah does your
mind hurt because mine is well I love
those books so much you mention
obviously stands for Ian Bernstein and
hay and Barrel yeah that we're just
using it as a way to describe the
different shifted dimensions and the
only proof of it being ever E is the way
we remember it correct collectively
because it's not like it's like six
people or mental swings pronounced and
everything right um and then like I
didn't go so far down the rabbit hole as
to like how much people have looked into
it but like people have taken pictures
of their old books that's why you heard
me call my mom earlier today yeah yeah
it was like mom if you have any of the
old Berenstein berry books can you take
them out and take a picture of them
because I'm almost positive that they're
going to have an a on them because
everybody else has already tried that
and that
all have a's and it just like it's
mind-fucking me so hard but I don't know
how far people have gone down the rabbit
hole is - okay like if they've been able
to find anything about it that's that's
where I stopped because I had to call my
mom basically I was there I was fine so
what are the other theories the other
theory is that there's time travelers
basically and you know the butterfly
effect so you go and you [ __ ] you
sneeze on somebody by accident because
you're trying not to touch anything and
change the course of history on and you
give a million people a disease that
they weren't equipped to have because
you travel backwards or like that
someone had traveled backwards in time
and you know change one little thing and
what we remembers Berenstein bears is
actually fair now it's berenstain bears
so that so the a is a ripple effect of
someone going back in time to something
clearly different you go back in time to
change the world but I was just
unaffected right but it would explain
why we all grew up it within a certain
timeframe I'll remember it being spelled
a certain way and then sometimes between
like a short period of time where maybe
none of us were really paying attention
someone changed it so now all of the
books are that we can't find a book that
has an e image because every single book
ever made was changed by that time
traveler in theory okay
okay no I'm just trying to well you have
to yeah you yeah it's difficult to wrap
your head around because you have to see
time as nonlinear yep to know to me you
have to see time is like this you know
whatever [ __ ] it's not a forward
moving not now is the present now is the
present now is the present it's like a
never [ __ ] looping not ever dick yeah
or you either believe in that or you
believe in parallel dimensions or you're
just like you guys are all [ __ ]
idiots
okay what do you think oh I mean I think
it's interesting because it could just I
mean here's the devil's advocate side of
me is saying it could just be one of
those things that the book was made
popular by someone who pronounced it
Berenstein even though who spelled
Berenstain okay hold on let me just
all ready ready so ready go ahead so say
the book was made popular however it was
made popular and the people or group of
people or one person who had a handle on
getting the book into the mainstream for
a lot of people to read pronounce that
Berenstein bears so hearing that
everyone bought the book not thinking to
check that it was actually spelled with
an e it could have just been spelled
with an A but they had taken someone's
word I heard it and I look can I rebut
so my rebuttal to that is that the
reason why I think a lot of people my
age or like parents that were that age
of that when their kids yeah we use that
book to learn how to read which is why
we all remember the way that it was
spelled like that's like you don't want
the same level as like some [ __ ]
third grade [ __ ] like you you open up a
barren seen bare book because you can
read any by the book right now are they
also on yourself hey they're like
they're all a on Wikipedia it's always
existed with an A but I think so many of
us are having a hard time with that
because we like when you first learn how
to read you remember how things are
spelt yeah no that's pronouncing so I
think you would be right that maybe
we're all just idiots because you know
we heard people saying steen so we saw
Steen or we didn't see stain yeah but we
learned how to read by reading barren
sea bears Sunnah mean so what the actual
[ __ ] it's very weird isn't it yeah it's
it's what I'm thinking show I thought
like I'll [ __ ] all that [ __ ] well it's
like in parents it's like in the movie
where something very very important but
also more of like a easter egg type
thing happens earlier on the movie and
you get to the later parts of the movie
and then they allude to that like you
should have been paying attention to
this which is one of those things and
you're like wait a minute I'm sure that
didn't happen but you have to rewatch
the movie to see that it did happen but
this is time so you can tree watch it
here I'm saying no well I think that the
amount of people they're adamant about
it being spelled with an E no wait
there's nothing you disagree there's
Evan is it disagree with here I know so
why are you saying no no I'm saying
know that it was spelled with an e I
don't have to go back and watch my life
you know it means yeah no but I'm just
saying the frustration of not being able
to go back and check like you would in a
movie but it's the same type of
situation where well yeah because we're
having experiences working on your so we
can't pitch yeah well you're so you're
so sure it was one way and then in a
movie you can go back and check and then
be like yeah it was or your minds blown
it wasn't but now we can't go back and
check oh yeah and it's weird to me that
all the copies are a now like you'd
think that that's the weirdest [ __ ]
part we're people looking at their home
copies dusting off their copies Maren
see bears and it has spelled an a when
you're so sure that exact copy it's not
a picture of the book online it's a real
thing right that's the scariest part
right well that that's that's why the
the theory is ridiculous and that we
switched parallel to parallel universes
or that there's a time traveler because
I'm sure if you dug up a picture of a
kid holding a bear and scene book when
you were a kid it would have an A on it
okay there's got to be like a an
explanation for this none that's why
it's a really great conspiracy theory
and it just recently like came up yeah
what well I'm seeing better think I
think who wrote the book yeah but that's
why that's why I said earlier I haven't
gotten so far down the rabbit hole to
see if someone who contacted the author
and you know what everything what the
deal is because I don't I didn't read
that far if you do please let me know
because I'm dying well now I need to
hear Helens front what I'm from what
I've read it seems like people have
exhausted their options and that their
their answer is a there's no other
answer there's no other answer even
though we the only thing that we all
remember isn't E but that's all the
proof that we have is that we all
remember it's being spelled with an E
Wow right is it possible that the book
was made to teach kids how to spell so
they threw a misspelling on the cover
just to be like hey this is not how you
spell and then in the book it's the real
no way spelling
no way nope okay and what the [ __ ] is
happening here because did someone just
like sneak back in time and then change
the name of that book and then come back
and like yeah people are saying John
tighten or whatever yeah Crichton I love
that guy look I love his diary man I
went down that was the reason why I
wanted one of the reasons why it took me
so long to prep for this podcast because
I went down his rabbit hole and someone
had actually hired a private in bed
coast-to-coast a.m. or FM or the radio
station that does that kind of thing
dunno I'm talking no yeah but remember
he had that that post on Reddit and
several years answer oh oh yeah yeah
people cuz he's a time traveler yeah
yeah yeah no I know who you're tired
yeah yeah I was reminding anyone who's
yeah we reference out the first yeah um
I brought him up for some reason people
are saying so you know maybe he went
back in time and [ __ ] his [ __ ] but
that's an example of a person who now
was the time traveler oh I remember I
was gonna say good thought train Jenna
thank you I went down his rabbit hole
and someone had hired a private
investigator to look into that guy and
they used like the IP addresses that he
was using Peter Peter John and found out
that it could be a person I think I
screamed tried to his name but I wasn't
going to talk about it because I thought
we had already talked about one last one
but I was too excited about it salon
couldn't person that he he could be a
person I didn't buy a name of like John
hab neck or something like that and that
his brother actually had set up a
foundation of sorts so that they could
get money and they had copier in like a
copyrights for his name or like if he
wanted to write a book or make money or
something that way so that he really is
a real person that he fabricated the
whole thing to cover his bases yeah but
like they tracked his IP address and
their their address and they were like
alright you're not a [ __ ] time
traveler you're just this [ __ ] guy
who made up this very elaborate story to
try and make some money bro damn right
now isn't it disappointing yeah but I
mean it not surprising but disappointing
I wanted to believe well think about
this hey Jenna if your time for
or okay you have the ability to travel
time whether it's eat something you've
created it's a physical invention a
time-traveling machine or you found a
way to jump back into time you wouldn't
tell anyone of course you wouldn't right
absolutely well I mean think about it
because you've discovered this way to go
back in time and you've learned the ins
and outs of what to do and how to do it
right and not to [ __ ] [ __ ] up like the
last thing you're gonna do is tell
someone wait so like oh hold on before
we move forward say you have a time
machine how do you know the ins and outs
of things and how not to [ __ ] up because
I feel like I would [ __ ] everything
erroneous nobody would teach you how to
not [ __ ] up that's that's so besides the
point I I think that's a valid question
but I'm saying is like let's just skip
to the point of view having understood
time-travel okay
like you have gotten to the point
whether there's been trial and error
people have died whatever you learned
how to travel time uh-huh that means in
my opinion that there could be people
right now who know how to travel time
and do it as they please and one of the
trips was taken by one of the amateurs
in the club and he [ __ ] one little
flower up and now it's Berenstain Bears
like theorem saying like the ya know
that's a theory yeah but I'm saying like
I was saying I wanted to believe but
yeah but the guy that's what I'm just
trying to refute the guy who's like I'm
a time travel ask me anything no you
wouldn't do that if you're a time
traveler you're risking everything I
feel like I would I mean you're risking
your risking nobility I would go like
into like I don't know the Renaissance
and I would walk up with a boombox and I
would just start breakdance noble oh
everybody's [ __ ] no that's no I'm
talking about present day okay then I
would gather the year that you learned
how to time-travel 2015-2020 whatever
year was the learned how to time travel
yeah you're not going to go to that
period and go on to Reddit and do an AMA
and say ask me anything about time
travel like that's that's clearly
projecting being a fake hmm if you're a
real time traveler you're not going to
tell everyone or anyone I'm going to
tell your club mates of the TAM Travel
Club who knows
[ __ ] function in 1850 and come back
at this [ __ ] drop of a repo who's to
say that where he where is he from
like the on the blog it said that he had
come to like two thousand or something
like that and then he was came back
present-day because he wanted to see the
y2k bug so that's why he was kind of
like in in this time member that I read
I read that completely ridiculous that
he might cuz he had also predicted that
the the United States would be in a
civil war in 2015 yeah so it's not
completely ridiculous that he would come
to a certain period in time and be like
hey guys I'm a time traveler it's not
your it's not his present what our
present is is not his no I understand
his present is different than ours but
like you said you would go back into the
Stone Age with a boom box that's great
like yeah what but like that like you do
[ __ ] like that and you know blow
people's minds for two seconds then you
bounce and they're like what the [ __ ]
was that I was high and then that's over
with you're not you're not answering a
panel of questions to try to educate the
people on something that you would never
want to share I feel like I would want
to share why you're risky traveler
because I just want you guys to know
that that's possible so reach for your
dreams seems like it seems like should
that ever happen to someone or if it
already has it seems just like
counterintuitive and very risky to tell
people especially strangers about it why
cuz you want to change the natural
course of history what if you are well
what if you want to be the only one you
know about to be able to do that like
that's pretty selfish well Jenna there
are a lot of idiots out there and if you
tell the Internet had a time travel then
all [ __ ] could break loose and like I
think that that's that's awesome cuz I
know you're clearly continuing to
disagree on this matter which is fine I
like this anyways it was good I would
still take my boombox back and dance for
some [ __ ] dollars take my
hoverboard back and our blow people's
minds but I wouldn't sit there and be
like ask me questions I'll educate you I
would I'd be like guys I'm gonna sit in
the middle of town tomorrow at noon all
right you guys ask me your questions I'm
very you bring here your flute okay and
and Jacob you bring a bunch of [ __ ]
wine let's all get our minds blown yeah
Barry you bring
Lieut that's what I would do would be
awesome
all right and then I'd be like all right
friends see you later remember don't
kill each other okay
it's not cool all right we have some
more to get through are you dump all the
Aetherius okay that was a good one that
was really good starting one it's crazy
right yeah okay I'm gonna save my best
one for last my first one
all right so coca-cola coke the company
coke the theory is coke had an original
formula if you will of coca-cola and up
until 1985 it was huge
it was like the biggest pop you could
buy it was the best soda everyone loved
it and in 1985 they came out with new
coca-cola which was their new thing it
was just I don't know we it was
basically like when a new you know Pepsi
zero
you know something comes out that's new
but it was just called the new Co whole
as far as I know and it did not do well
people did not like it they said this is
bad go back to what you did before we
want that we will buy that mm-hmm so
they did they went back to the original
formula and then killed so the theory is
that they purposefully took the good
stuff off the market and introduced a
intentionally inferior formula for the
new coke to be like hey guys here's this
new product knowing full well it's [ __ ]
and people don't want it but they did
that because it would create even more
demand for their old product to be
brought about the coke they had cocaine
in it no I don't think I don't think
this is the same thing because if you
took the cocaine coke off the market and
then tried to feed people sugary soda
I'd be pretty pissed well I don't I I
this was a short blog that I read on
this so the cocaine thing it might be
the old coke head cocaine you know I'm
saying good the point is here's your
drugs without drugs
hope you like it yeah I mean I don't
think they I don't think it was that I
think it was just a like I read the blog
and it was pretty like sort of extensive
and it said they just made an inferior
formula so they didn't they say they
left out the drugs they just said
made it worse well what year is it again
1985 85
okay so I believe that that's our 95
they came around 10 surely making a
shitty product to get everybody really
missing their old exactly and then they
brought it back and destroyed that's
that's the theory I don't think that's
that's far off at all
they asked coke execs to make a
disgusting soda
well coke execs were asked about it
obviously they denied but I mean think
about it this way like you create a
product that's really really great and
then it's slowly like okay it's a great
product but now it's kind of just
everyone knows it like how do you
without having the technology or
knowledge or anything to make a better
product how do you make that more
coveted you take it away and you bring
something else out so they want it back
you know it's it seems like kind of it
seems like very plausible okay but that
also seems like it got a gigantic risk
like what if they lose everyone that's
ever liked coke because now it tastes
like [ __ ] when you have such a close
competitor in Pepsi maybe it is maybe
there's a big risk
but maybe it takes knowing that your
first product was that good it's going
to cause that much demand not just
registration you know okay hell of a
drug do you didn't watch the Pels oh I
forgot about that yeah I think it never
mind never mind never mind guys cocaine
just [ __ ] it's not my joke okay um
joke thief
so you don't remember Crystal Pepsi then
is that a spell job no Crystal Pepsi was
like Pepsi decided one time that they
were gonna make this clear like sprite
Pepsi so that was like Gatorade ice Cola
without any of the cold coloring yeah
and it just looked like sprite it tastes
like Cola yeah and people like this is
[ __ ] disgusting Jesus [ __ ] you but
now people like buy it on eBay and
chicks are like a novel yeah I think
that Gatorade ice did the same thing
they made a line of Gatorade where it
was clear like water but it was all
these all they had a whole line of
flavors
I think they brought it back but when I
was in school because I was was a kid
during that we a lot of my classes
didn't allow anything but water at your
desk so I would naturally just fill up a
water bottle with Gatorade ice and I
would just be so happy drinking my water
a Spanish teacher really like to do it
with vodka I think I was like well on my
way to doing that was look like in high
school then it was vodka and I wasn't
I'm just kidding I didn't drink vodka in
class do you really think that coke
would do that though that they would
take it off the market if there was a
company let [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] out there
is a company with the balls enough to do
that and come out on top it would be
coke you think so yeah oh yeah I mean I
think so I don't I think out of all the
conspiracy theories I wrote down that's
probably the most likely to be true
really yes we'll do well it's okay so
say except for the Aladdin one I think
that Apple put out like a an iPhone 6
and they all really like them and then
they put out a really shitty phone next
maybe with as the new coat well dad I
hate this mom you hate it I have a lot
of problems with this phone I love mine
I have so many problems with my phone ok
but do you understand I'm saying though
like if they put out a shitty phone and
you buy it
hmm and would that make you want your
old phone or would it make you want your
a different phone both it's risky that's
what I'm saying it's a ballsy move to I
would be like [ __ ] you i'm i'm i yeah i
mean my phone if this is true that
happened a lot of coke fans switched to
pepsi or whatever competitor was the
best and they were like you know what
[ __ ] coke and then one coke brought the
old one back they were lucky i want to
try it and then they're like [ __ ] it i
miss it I'm back at coke like they don't
even care you don't you can't afford to
Harbor hatred against a company when a
product is so good that you can't refuse
it so for me like I mean I don't hate
this phone I was being dramatic I like
this fonts and iPhones I've loved
iPhones but if they did release a phone
that was [ __ ] I would undoubtedly move
to Android and I would find something I
liked and maybe fall in love but then if
they brought the next phone back and it
was like the Super Apple iPhone of all
times which was a mix of the old school
and new technology of course I would
want it it's like I can never ever
afford to harbor a resenting grudge any
sort of like I'm not
to be a part of that anymore when a
product is this good when it when it's
coke and when it's the iPhone you can
only do that for so long and then you
like you want the best and you know they
have the best they've proven it they
showed you the shitty and then they're
like you know what [ __ ] it here that I'm
not saying an apple does that or anyone
else does I'm saying well if my only
choice though was like shitty coke new
revamped coke old coke leg better coke
or whatever or Pepsi whose just [ __ ]
chilling I'd be like you know what I'm
gonna stick with the company that's not
freaking the [ __ ] out over here
absolutely making a bunch of weird [ __ ]
absolutely but think about this there
was no more coke on the planet I'd be
fine being like hey I'll just have a
Pepsi people who trap people who drink
soda religiously are so hell-bent on
their soda
they soda for people is so important to
what kind so if I'm like a coke guy
through and through I love Coca Cola
it's my [ __ ] and 1985 comes and they
release new coke I am going to be a
bitter human being for however many
years or in very many months it takes
for them to bring back the old coke I'm
never going to switch I'm just gonna be
a bitter [ __ ] I'm gonna be
pissed off at everyone because coke took
away the good product and then when they
bring it back I'm gonna say finally I
got my [ __ ] back there are those people
there are those types of people out
there who exist who are so stubborn and
will never ever for their own even to
risk their own [ __ ] happiness insanity
switch over because they love a company
so much that they hate it all I keep
thinking about is that guy in that
commercial for I think it was Burger
King but like he went to Wendy's or some
[ __ ] wanted a whopper he's like give me
my whopper like this is not a whopper
yeah yeah yeah starik cause he's not
lipping out cuz it's not a whopper
that's all I keep thinking yeah that's
exactly what it is it's like that guy
will [ __ ] crazy about their [ __ ] man
people are and you got to respect them
like they're there they're willing to
hate everyone in hate life because they
physically can't abandon a brand and
they hate what their brand has become
but they're never gonna leave it not
never but you know they're not well I
want to know people think about that one
cuz I'm
sure that I'm buying it I would say that
was probably the most possible one if
you had said that it was Pepsi and they
released Crystal Pepsi and people were
pissed and wanted regular Pepsi back I
believe you I'm not buying the we
changed our formula to make you guys
want our old formula I am buying that
I'm buying the new formula that's how
much I'm buying now more
give me my whopper okay I'll go on to my
next one
what mom just this is fun go ahead okay
so my next conspiracy theory was pretty
interesting who found it down a hall but
it's the idea that the entire
international space system and like the
moon landing like all of that stuff was
all staged which is not new but I
watched a video on YouTube showing you
know quote conclusive evidence that this
is all staged underwater and that
they're all like super water suits
because you can hear them and it sounds
like they're talking underwater and an
air bubble releases from what effects oh
my god and the video is like it was
making me laugh really hard because you
know how like if you want to show
something in detail you zoom in on it
and you play it slower but it just kept
getting closer and slower and closer on
one single air bubble in like this
grainy picture it was good stuff but I
mean I said I could see that honestly I
could see that being like we want people
to think that we're in space right now
yes here's why I don't think that's true
good one was the space landing the first
moon landing start
I don't know 70 something for me I got a
D in this 1970 something right I would
say in the 70s you know what I'll look
at okay look it up I'm just gonna go out
on a limb here and say that they didn't
have the technology to have an entire
[ __ ] film crew underwater you know
just shoot something that extends that's
a that's a good thought 1969 six now
let's close that is a good thought that
they would not have the capability to
shoot all of that
underwater yeah because even now they
have the capability to in water but if
you're talking like a whole shoot with
the [ __ ] stage and a giant ship
there's logistics there's people there's
crews like even that's hard right now
think about in 1969 you [ __ ] kidding
me that's like I don't know how that's
even possible well they were so a lot of
those conspiracy theories that they
staged the moon landing did not include
the underwater here okay so you're
saying most of it has to do with the
space station the International the
International which is currently a thing
yet that's all staged underwater that
nobody even up there but if I could
fight a conspiracy theory with the
conspiracy theory first ya know do it
then how do you account for all the UFO
sightings near the Space Station if
they're underwater cgi-bin
do great UFOs now being the guy that's
sitting there like you're an editor or
some [ __ ] and you specialized in that
you went to school for it and you have
somebody that works for the government
being like all right listen in I know
this is ridiculous
but all these [ __ ] are
underwater right now we need you to put
something in there that looks like a
really good UFO but not too good look
kind of good oh my god you guys are just
sitting at your desk with your coffee
being like the [ __ ] am i doing right now
oh my god yeah I don't know I don't know
maybe there is a guy who's the UFO
animate heard it sounds like they're
talking underwater cuz they're talking
through radios yeah yeah what I mean how
do you even know what it sounds like
when someone's talking underwater no I
don't know played a reference is there
like radios we know what it sounds like
when people talk to each other
underwater because they're talking
through radios so they like it sounds
like they're underwater because they're
talking through radios do you know yeah
whatever the water does your voice the
radio is doing a similar thing it's
distorting the voice wait well they both
require you wear a helmet so that's a
yeah be in a fire you could be in the
air doesn't matter
yeah but I really like if you find that
video you just watch the zoom of the
bubble on this air bubble because it's
playing it like so [ __ ] slow and
really gotta get it man there's a weird
air bubble weird air but don't know
what's happening but come on dude it's
an interesting idea though I think it's
creative and I you know you'd have to
look for some more reasons as to why
someone would want to make an entirely
underwater stage to International Space
Station you need to have some a lot of
countries on phone yeah for sure for a
lot of different people ready to shoot a
big underwater production hmm that's a
good one it's an interesting yeah that's
right it is
they're not even in space man they're
just underwater now and speaking of
space square space
it was nice enough to sponsor this
podcast you guys should go check them
out at squarespace.com they have so many
templates they work on mobile it comes
with a free online store so if you're
building a website blog online shop it
comes with that it comes with mobile
versions so you don't have to zoom in a
bunch when you're on your phone which we
all know how knowing that is 24/7
customer support chat they they hop on
the chat with you literally 24/7 any
problem you're having middle of the
night they will hop on and solve your
problem Squarespace comm check it out
and you can get a free trial but you can
also get 10% off your website products
code JJ at checkout and 10% off there
you go let us know how you like it
because Squarespace is a [ __ ] they gave
a shirt yeah I do good stuff and you
know who that's great for people that
are writing like I don't know so you're
a mom and you're writing a mom blog and
you're a year up cuz your baby's
sleeping for like an hour at a time yeah
up in the middle yeah yeah I need I need
support now and you know what like it
when five years ago when you were that
person and you wanted to just do a blog
for yourself because you had an interest
you just had to accept that it was gonna
look shitty because you didn't hire a
team of people to get it you don't it
looks professional as [ __ ] and you don't
need anyone to help you but they're 24/7
customer support Thank You squares thank
you Squarespace alright so moving on
right yes
my turn um yeah
okay you're gone
alright so Fight Club mm-hmm popular
movie that it is okay so the the the
conspiracy is gotta [ __ ] smile on
your face that Fight Club is a grown-up
version of Calvin and Hobbes okay
like it's it's exactly the same you you
read Calvin Hobbes right yeah okay
Calvin Hobbes was the best they're just
friends the best cartoon ever what do
you know like the more of it well tell
me more of it hey so Calvin Hobbes I
literally read all the books I love
Calvin Hobbs so much it's my favorite
cartoon of all time what do you call a
cartoon in a book that's not our cartoon
on TVs cartoon right I just cartoon I'm
a comic okay comic sorry this word was
escaping me okay
so Calvin and Hobbes is said to be okay
so basically Calvin and Hobbes is about
this kid named Calvin he has this his
friend named Hobbes and is a tiger but
it's really just a stuffed animal but
when you know people aren't really
looking or not paying attention it's
it's Hobbes it's a live Tiger who's his
best friend and he goes on adventures
with him and that's they go on
adventures The Adventures of Calvin
Calvin and Hobbes in it's one of the
best right that's what I said they're
just best friends yeah but he's he's a
stuffed animal okay he comes what anyway
or in Calvin's mining comes life anyways
France 16 year spoiler alert for people
who haven't seen Fight Club turn it off
now turn it off now so in Fight Club
Tyler Durden who's played by Brad Pitt
is find out a figment of the narrator's
imagination or Edward Edward Norton's
character they never give him a name
it's always the narrower gnar narrator
so you find out the end that Tyler
Durden is not a real person he's just
he's part of Edward Norton's brain the
whole time he's a figment of his matte
imagination okay his name is Tyler
sounds a lot like Tiger here we go which
is hop in Calvin and Hobbes so Tyler is
the figment of cap of narrators and
agitation and and tiger Hobbes is a
figment of Calvin's imagination that he
comes like because the the comics always
end with him being a
a doll laying on the bed it always ends
with that so let me let me keep going
all right go ahead I know I'm all in go
ahead
so Calvin often refers to Hobbes as his
best friend's life sidekick in the movie
Fight Club the narrator's best friend
slash sidekick is Tyler Tyler Durden so
they're going on these adventures for
them it's going underneath the building
and fighting each other at night but
he's with him
they're psychic and they get in fights
all the time because you know they're
they're spending so much time together
of course they're going to get in fights
Calvin and Hobbes got in fights too
about all sorts of stuff without
arguments with his parents and being
grown-up at being a kid all right
this theory is backed by the scene where
Tyler Durden is wearing a fur coat in
Fight Club why would he be wearing a fur
coat if he wasn't Wow reincarnated from
being a tiger in his past life and
that's how you're being Hobbs in Calvin
and Hobbes a card drops like oh wow that
was definitely real okay so the theory
is that they are Calvin and Hobbes or
the story is based off of Calvin and
Hobbes
yeah whatever came first the chicken or
the egg so I don't know when Calvin and
Hobbes is written but long before Fight
Club yeah so so they made Fight Club has
a derivative story from Calvin and
Hobbes
okay I thought you were trying to like
say that they were Calvin and Hobbes
they were Calvin tops they took that
they took the story directly and ice-t
got it interesting I mean is that a
conspiracy theory no oh yeah why would
he be wearing a fur coat that's not a
coincidence
I'll show the whole thing that his name
is Tyler and he's a tiger and they're
there in their head the whole time like
Hobbes I had to learn this and it was a
shitty day for me when I learned this
but Hobbes isn't real he's a stuffed dog
stuffed toys the stuff
or that Calvin plays with Calvin's crazy
man but then by that logic isn't every
story of a child having a toy come to
life Fight Club
no we're worse where's the tiger like
the fur coat there's no she's got
nothing to refute that with us I got
nothing man I got nothing drops mic I
have nothing to say all right ah there
we go that's my second conspiracy theory
Wow Wow Wow I mean I get it okay the
stories they are similar when you you
know look at them from a distance but
then why is it I'm just questioning why
isn't every story of a child that has a
toy come to life and is their best
friend why aren't those Fight Club also
it's different why is it different
because not every kid does not [ __ ]
Winnie the Pooh well because they're not
sidekicks they're not like they don't go
fight each other and go on adventures
together like sidekicks like Calvin and
Hobbes they're like two peas in a pod
they don't go anywhere without each
other like all these other stories say
Toy Story Andy goes to his friend's
house and leaves his [ __ ] toys at
home like they are always together and
they are always communicating whether or
not it's really happening in Calvin's
head and Hobbes is fur filled head
they're communicating the whole time
they're together always all right it's
okay and you know another thing is like
in Fight Club [ __ ] will happen where
where narrator gets like physically all
like pushed or physically affected by
the presence of Tyler Durden and like
when they get when they punch each other
like what he maybe you have to assume he
punched himself because he's in fig
Mary's imagination but in Calvin and
Hobbes Calvin will be on a sled three
times his size and get pushed by Hobbs
how do you explain that I guess they're
crazy
z Edward Norton was crazy and Fight Club
Calvin is crazy [ __ ]
he's abs mind I guess I don't know the
answer to that
there is no hitter that is the answer
well did anybody ask the the writer of
Fight Club if that's where he drew his
inspiration which somebody has to now
maybe I will send him an email all right
I mean it's enema snapshot you should
send mr. nip shoot story
- one's not really a conspiracy theory
either okay but I mean I think I'm only
on you three okay um oh yeah then should
I pick a last one yeah because my other
two are just not as good as my last one
and we're like cruising okay the one
that I really want to talk about even
though it's not a hundred percent of
conspiracy theory really um is called
Oak Island
I don't oak island did I talk about this
in the last one cuz I'm talking I don't
think you do so my first exposure to Oak
Island was on the show ancient aliens
what you all know I'm very obsessed with
and I love uh it's just an island off of
Nova Scotia Canada and people there's
like something in the ground it started
with like an 18 year old or I've read
you from there to work in 1795 eighteen
year old Daniel McGinnis after observing
lights coming from the island discovered
a circular depression in a clearing on
the southeastern side of the island the
Jason - the clearing was a tree with the
tackle blah blah blah
basically he gets a couple of his
friends and they start digging
underneath this spot on this island in
1795 and they weren't able to get very
far about eight years later after the
1795 dig according to the original
articles another company examined what
was to become known as the money pit
which makes me laugh because that's my
brother used to call me when I was a kid
he called you money pick yeah he said
that Jen is the money the money pit cuz
you throw money into it you never get
any out of it it's really I was like
seven Devon but I'm hungry um so then
they people kept digging and digging
digging they continued their excavate
down to approximately 90 feet and found
layers of logs charcoal putty and
coconut fiber at 40 50 and 60 feet and
this is still all you know around that
same time now fast forward till whenever
the [ __ ] okay
people keep trying to dig and dig and
dig on this island called Oak Island and
they keep heading metal wood putty
charcoal they keep hitting layers and
layers and layers of things and at
several different stages there seems to
be like booby traps like it'll start
flooding do you know what I mean
I want to try and find you some of it
and people keep dying trying to lick a
handful of people have died but now but
like seriously fast forward until
further excavations were made in 1866
1893 1909 1931 1935 1936 1959 all the
way up until now 2011 people are still
trying to dig this [ __ ] thing there
were layers of I think it's a like
actual oak like oak underground yeah
like they've chopped it up and they
[ __ ] put it down like to cover up the
layer so that no it what it said that
there's treasure under there they said
that they found a rock that with the
marking on it that they believes meant
that there's treasure under it and it's
been privately funded in the past to dig
in there somebody built a giant crane to
bring it onto this I try and keep the
treasure for themselves if they ever
found it well yeah so and what's been
happening is that you know every once in
a while someone will decide they really
want to dig there so they buy parts of
the island and they buy the rights to be
able to dig on the land and they will
funnel infinite resources that they have
or can fundraise around them to try and
dig like somebody informed the king at
the time I think it said King George the
sixth about developments on Oak Island
like people have been really interested
on the treasure and the third guessing
is underneath it and people have put so
much money into trying to dig it since
1795 and no one even now with our
current
modern-day technology cannot and I think
one of the last ones are what they
covered in engineering that was blowing
my [ __ ] mind was so they got down to
a certain point and they decided to pour
red paint into the water it was flooding
and it came out from three different
points like channels on the island so
you're like alright we want to see where
the water is coming from so they pour
the right paint in there and all of a
sudden it's like basically surrounding
them so this like trap or like you know
booby traps
it's like rigged it's so sophisticated
that somebody prior to 1795 had dug over
a hundred feet into this island like
plummet basically yet ridiculously far
into the ground to bury something and it
had set up three underground water
tunnels to a specific point more than a
hundred feet in the ground so if you dug
that far trap know so that if you dug
that far it would instantly come
flooding from not one not two but three
different points to make sure that you
could never get to the bottom of it do
you know what I'm saying
so that people keep funneling money into
it and it keeps like flooding like they
keep discovering different ways that
it's booby-trapped so you can never get
to the bottom can you imagine how many
people died I think uh I've looked at
there was one early then there was like
four and then there were six that had
died from like an engine exploding one
of them fell into it um a bunch of
different people like depending on what
you read there's some people that are
like oh it's cursed or whatever I just
think that it's some of the hazards that
come with trying to independently dig a
massive hole on an island but just
imagine it's 1795 and you're like are
yar I'm a pirate
I should bury me treasure you really
have the capability of creating this
like no [ __ ] way man you know what I
mean yeah at all the one thing that I
always get troubled by when it comes to
conspiracy theories is things that were
engineered or created by a man or
thought to be by man and that's the only
logical kind of solution at this point
that is outsmarting us today that's
something that just terrifies me so
something like that where someone I mean
that we with what all the [ __ ] we have
today all the technology all the
manpower machines and everything we
cannot figure out that we can't crack
that code we can't find a way around
that crazy like plumbing they plump they
plumbed it right well that that was the
craziest part at least when I was
watching on ancient aliens when I was
reading on this was that if you find
this hole and you just keep digging
through layers of metal and wood and all
different kinds of things you're like
all right well eventually I'm going to
get to the bottom so and then all of a
sudden you realize that you're dealing
with a very sophisticated booby trap
because it's not just that they dug a
hole and they put all of those like I
think everybody said there's 22 inches
of metal like it's ridiculous the way so
obviously ancient aliens says that it
was probably aliens well that it was
created by technology that was before
its time someone had helped them or they
had whatever but just that any of itself
is more than impressive but what's more
impressive is that they had the
capabilities of digging three underwater
tunnels they literally were plumbing in
more 7095 better than we can even dig
now more than a hundred feet underground
to one specific point to make this like
thing to make this tunnel and there are
reports although no one has been able to
confirm it that they had broken through
to not the bottom but like a cave layer
and that it had collapsed like a little
while afterwards so people still want to
you know go down there and find it but
so what you reach a [ __ ] cave then
what you reach another [ __ ] country
underneath it you know what I mean who
the [ __ ] knows it that's crazy to me
that's a little I'm kind of stumped but
how do you like how do you even dig this
is beyond because I'm an idiot when it
comes to this stuff but like how do you
dig underwater tunnels to you know
they're booby traps so if you dig it'll
flood but it's not flooding your log
digging yeah so will that I mean that's
that's crazy
like my brain hurts if you know how many
people died now like how many people
died trying to [ __ ] make the thing
like I don't know how that's physically
possible to dig like unlike underwater
where there's water pressure coming in
and not get flooded yourself either they
had some insane amount of alien
technology or it was one of the most
brilliant booby traps booby traps floor
plans of all time like he was an
engineering god and he went in there it
was like I I got an idea guys justjust
listen to me let's get like a hundred
people get some metal if we go this way
it won't fly yeah just doing everyone
here's willing to die right yeah exactly
but now that's that's that's i got
nothing i got nothing yeah i mean for
those of you that like ancient aliens
the show or you have seen that episode
you know what i'm talking about because
they show you the visual of the island
what it looks like it's the locations of
the three channels that are flooding
into this and who's to say that you know
once you reach those three underwater
booby trap channels that there are
seventeen more before you ever get to
the bottom it wouldn't be the most
surprising thing considering what they
have discovered already but people
continue that lore of treasure and
treasure hunting is so like crazy deeply
ingrained and people of you know they'll
do anything to look for treasure and
since 1795 people have been trying to
get to whatever is under there and no
one has been able to hmm Wow but I
really like it can you show me that
episode of camera watching absolutely I
will show you all of the episodes oh if
we watch it before like 11:00 p.m. I'll
stay awake I know I always joke that I'm
I'm like so obsessed with ancient aliens
I love it yeah and whenever I show it to
someone else they immediately fall
asleep but to be fair we watch it late
at night and I'm already tired so if you
watched it me it's not just you it's
like everyone I've ever that's a thing
I'm interested in that it's just like
the slow shots and the steady voice
that'll put you to sleep was making
about his electric his hair is up here
he's using his hand oh I'm not talking
about you're talking about George Oh
sooo close we're talking about the
narrator who's like oh the narrator kids
week
Island yeah so it's like the voice is
just like okay go to sleep no talk about
not okay but okay you're different
you're you're different than me but I
still think I do have interest and I
want to watch it yeah I'll just let me
watch it I will find that episode for
you and there's also another episode of
underwater stuff that's really excellent
where they talk about underwater like
pyramids and [ __ ] which is [ __ ]
bananas I would watch the [ __ ] out of
that yeah um yeah okay Oak Island
hmm yeah I can't remember the name of
the episode but you know that's just one
thing that they covered where I'm just
sitting there in the edge of my seat
like everyone's asleep right now
and I'm [ __ ] losing my [ __ ] over here
okay yeah did you want to do your last
night yeah
so is this the Aladdin was right out of
waiting like all night this conspiracy
theory is about Aladdin let's go I'm
ready
all right the conspiracy theory is that
Aladdin is based in 10,000 300 AD
uh-huh which is in the future because
it's 2015 right now okay 10380 the
reason for this is that in a part of the
movie the genie says to Aladdin
your clothes are so third century do you
remember that he's insulting his clothes
mm-hmm cuz he looks like he's from the
third century problem here is they also
say in the movie that the genie has been
in his land for 10,000 years so the math
here leads you getting this I thinks
though he would never have seen the
third century if he was at land for
10,000 years but actually that was
meaning that the genie is man-made or
that the lamp is man-made no no that's
what it's saying is if he's being honest
and saying that is so third century he
would have had to be in the third
century to see it out of the genie out
of the bottle but what what is it the
word would we hunt it's not a bottle
it's a lamp lamp he would have been okay
so the genie
in the third century right now right
he's in the third century he's looking
around he's like oh I'm gaining
knowledge for what it looks like to
dress in the third century goes into the
land ten thousand years later which
leads you to ten thousand three hundred
ad he makes that reference you look like
you're from the third century with those
clothes so Aladdin is way in the future
it's a post-apocalyptic world where the
magic is not magic that they're using
it's actually the marvels of years of
futuristic science okay
and that's Aladdin okay nothing about a
line is as you thought it was it's all
futuristic it's completely postal op
apocalyptic zombies came and went
everything's dead what's boom was he
what's he what's Rajah he's a he's
probably some some monkey cyborg what's
Roger then whatever you want Roger to be
I don't know what happened I in 10380
okay just like you could probably have
free printing of human beings and
whatever animal you want the theory
completely rests on the idea that the
genie and the lamp are both man-made
who's to say that it was an ancient
aliens that you know had him in the
[ __ ] lamp and that he came out around
Aladdin's time that he had been in the
lamp for ten thousand years no the
argument isn't saying he wasn't in the
lamp the argument saying oh it's about
when he was in the lamp yeah right but
that that argument hinges on the fact
that the genie started being in the lamp
in the third century how else would he
know where the third century dress like
but what if he was in the lamp before
then like ten thousand years before then
and came out for a second I don't know
but they say in the movie he's only been
in the lamp for 10,000 years
so with that math he had to be out of
the way ever came back he never came I
said I've been in this lamp for ten
thousand years that's what he says
alright what if he's exaggerating cuz he
is pretty dramatic we'll give them that
okay all right what a exaggerating but
it's a weird number to pay ten thousand
years probably were in there for ten
thousand year what if he just made a
weird joke that's
same argument you can't double up those
are both the same argument him being
dishonest maybe he's just being dramatic
on both parts all right Pete maybe you
saw a picture well while he was hanging
out the Latin he saw a picture of
Aladdin's parents you know grandparents
well you guys have two less let us know
anything because I'm a hundred percent
sure that's true well I just wanna know
I mean what I mean I mean flying carpet
I mean that sounds post-apocalyptic to
me like some guy had to have dealt with
zombies on a carpet and was like you
know what I have an idea I could escape
all zombies if I could make this thing
fly boom gave it to a Latin they made
the movie sent it back in time with a
guy who changed the barren sea bears
full circle oh my god oh I just want to
know who Raja is in the future because
Raja is so [ __ ] miserable in the
whole movie like he just sits there and
listens to [ __ ] Jasmine complain all
the time about her first world problems
and he's like Hello
excuse you first post-apocalyptic world
problems I am a [ __ ] tiger in
captivity in your [ __ ] house when can
I leave don't pet me and tell me about
your [ __ ] problems that's why I want to
know what Raja is broch was probably a
mix of years and years of science
maybe animal testing an taboo and the
the Jafar's [ __ ] parrot or whatever
yeah you know what Aladdin's really
about is that animal all evening there's
talking animals in this movie like they
had to have advanced animals to the
point where they can probably
manufacture them and make them talk and
make them be friendly and make them not
eat you that bird was not friendly he's
he's devious he's shifty I wouldn't say
it's devious shady he's throwing [ __ ]
mr. Shane well then how come Roger can't
talk and tell Jasmine how much he's
gonna jump off a bridge if she doesn't
shut the [ __ ] up because that he didn't
get the voice also now in the future
they can choose which you said you
manufactures and how you want them it's
like a 3d printer but animals does so
she wanted a prisoner basically
yeah you little she's got a weird
complex okay she's got issues yeah she
does she doesn't know how to cut her
[ __ ] hair or get a hairbrush you look
dusty your hair isn't even not that cute
I lean on you the doubt
man so we can agree it's post-punk
epochal you know you might be right I
think I'm right you might be right I
think I'm right so does that mean that
your farce mustache is coming back into
style in the future yeah intense eight
thousand years approximately eight
thousand two hundred years ish give or
take so there will be genies and there
will be arranged marriages there will
only be genies when they arise out of
their lamp whether that is ten thousand
years or a different amount of beers I
think that depends on the genie you get
someone gonna make the lamp to put the
genie in like do you have to capture it
like I just want to know the logistics
of getting a genie in a bottle or a lamp
it's a different argument and that's one
that I am NOT attending which comes
first the genie or the lamp the lamp you
don't make a lamp with the genie already
in it you make the lamp the genie comes
to it no but like if the genie is ten
thousand years old already and he gets
put into a lamp for ten thousand years
wouldn't the genie come first lamp came
for us it's an old ass [ __ ] lamp duh
it's not lamps are like the oldest thing
ever
Julian it's not what what is something
that still exists that's like the oldest
[ __ ] oldest [ __ ] aliens a lamp why do
you have a lamp it's so old
really really not not like a like a
stick that was like sharpened at the end
lamp is older than any stick ever yeah I
feel you I know Wow
I think that the genie comes first and
then someone builds a lamp and someone
cast a spell on the genie and the new
lamp and that's the genius now the genie
doesn't have a spell cast on him he's
that's when he is born as a genie when
he's here when he appears when he is
spawned what is it
I don't know but when he is created as a
genie he knows that that is his cross to
bear he does not get to ever
I forgot Rosalie yeah there you go there
you go
I am so okay how about this though the
Aladdin and the Little Mermaid are the
same the genie story parallels a real
story except they live in parallel
universes and the genie never gets free
and legs except he does sort of except
he doesn't get to be happy because he
still has to help the Latin in jazz the
end but Ariel and Ariel side job is a PA
for the film shoots of the underwater
Space Station movies other shooting now
that's Eric's shop no she's she's cheeky
a Oh your shoot a gun my god if she
brings coffee to the director underwater
that's what she does in Sebastian and
flounder her little fish slaves they
don't work they're her pets no they're
not her pets she bosses them around okay
she's a [ __ ] to them she makes them do
[ __ ] for her yeah Five Guys is so fun so
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] you alright alright
good one yeah that's good oh my god I
just like that your two main [ __ ]
theories are that Calvin and Hobbes and
Fight Club are the same and that Aladdin
is a future apocalyptic [ __ ] Dan and
that [ __ ] matters
oh thank Squarespace for putting up with
our [ __ ] okay he's crazy you guys
are awesome check out Squarespace comm
products code JJ at checkout 10% off
your website let us know how you like it
also please in the comments respond to
all the [ __ ] we Berenstein bears out of
our mouth today Berenstein bears on what
no get seriously why don't you just go
in I mean if you want to respond to any
of them that's the one I want to hear
begin also Oak Island that's pretty cool
it's really cool um but yeah thank you
guys for watching
we'll leave act next week is another
podcast hit us up in the comments and we
love you guys
I'm trying 5 glucose parity dairies
alright there is temple die of the
period I have a conspiracy theory that
you will forget to plug in your
headphones so I'll have to charge them
before next podcast that is my love you
your blog